I feel like you should be playing sad
music right now guess I'm gonna be
shaving my armpits for the first time
I'm real excited I'm expecting it to
hurt what have I shave a nerve you know
this is 28 years of growth this is gonna
see war very soon if I'm going with a
let's go all the way weird too much
laughs too much it's chilly all right
here we go
maybe we could donate this hair it's
like this is something you would find
under your bed and then feel like we're
really sad about your life I'm gonna cut
shave this bear that any woman who's
ever shaved it and their entire life I
had to do this like even once a week I
just be like not going outside the house
women I give you mad props for doing
this on the Reg you guys can keep your
hair I don't mind
now my shoulders getting tired because
it's just like holding it up like you
can't even see what you're doing I don't
know what this is impossible I'm worried
too about when this grows back you know
like when you shave your downstairs
there's always like that weird
uncomfortable stage where you're like
itchy and it's doubly and you're like oh
do people get razor prints under their
armpits I bet you somebody's gonna cut
themselves on the armpit today oh man
that now oh yeah I got cut on that one
you can feel the breeze it's cold when
you don't have any hair on your armpits
it's like it's like an old uncles chin
or something I think it's all gone whoa
I hate myself a little bit about that
whoa God I mean I feel like I didn't
touch something that touched since the
fourth grade it doesn't feel like an
armpit anymore oh it's like fresh shave
balls but in my armpits makes your skin
very sensitive kind of burns a little
bit actually this is the weirdest thing
it's too much work well I quit after
doing one because my arm hurt it was
interesting it was a lot harder than I
thought it would be women do this all
the time like they get used to it from a
very young age I do feel a little more
free it sucks
guys don't shave our pits and if some
dude isn't into you because you got
hairy pits come on
I'm not going around looking at people's
armpits so I'm talking to you if my girl
like wanted me to do this for her on the
regular she really liked it would I do
it yeah I wouldn't be happy about it but
I'd do it people shouldn't shave why do
they invent shaving thank god you're not
asking me to shave my legs because
that's like a whole another smorgasbord
of that we'd be getting into if I had to
shave my legs I don't know maybe we'll
find out